so wildcards I mean these the classic
example of this is you're you wanted to
list files and you sale to find all the
Word documents on my system so if you
add a command line prompt on Windows you
would say something like dir star dot
it's dogs or docx same sort of thing
works in UNIX you can do LS dot dot docx
and then the output you'll get there is
a list of all the files that end with
the extension dot doc X so what's going
on here how does this actually work we
generally talk about wildcards when
we're thinking about files and things
but similar things are used in other
places all I talk about in files with
the same approach can be used elsewhere
so what a wild-card is is just the idea
that certain characters rather than
being compared literally against the
actual file name or the directory name
our interpreters having a special
meaning so the the obvious one is star
which rings anything we tend to think
about it as anything so what we're
saying here is show me all the files dir
LS depending on using DOS or Linux all
the files is anything dot docx so what's
actually going on here well let's first
of all think about the different
wildcards we can get because there are
various things the two main ones you
come across are star which means match
anything and you get question mark which
means match any character so for example
if we wanted to find all the letters to
mothers then we might do a search for M
question while m dot doc X that would
then find mum doc X and it would also
find mom doc XE would also find mom docx
and you'll find m 3 m dot dot so it'll
match any character instead of the
question mark so it's basically saying
at this point I'm not going to specify
what's here you match any character
there's a you could also combine this so
you can search for M question mark
question mark m dot docx which of course
won't match any of these because they
have two characters there
but would match for example dot dot X
like that so you'd match something like
that because it's two there and again
this could be M 1 for m dot dot X or if
you're hacking you might have dogs dogs
X so what does this actually match what
about star then so start means match
anything and this way actually varies
slightly between Windows and UNIX or
something between us and UNIX so for
example let's say we have pre and then
we match that to star dot docx and so
this would match prefix dot docx it
would also match prepare dot docx etc so
anything that begins with P re it'll
match there you could do star IX dot
docx which was then match suffix
and of course UNIX dot because this is
mean anything that we match here and
then we will find IX dot first Iseman
any run of characters from zero or more
this would also match of course IX dot
doc and this would have matched free dot
doc and things because it's basically
zero more any characters that we like
you can get slightly more advanced ones
so UNIX allow you to do something let's
have a look you can say a dash Z in
square brackets file dot doc and this is
getting UNIX would allow you to match a
file doc and even might as you might t
file dot doc but it wouldn't match three
file dot doc because what we said here
is it match any character this between
upper case and upper case said so this
is a lower case B so this wouldn't match
whereas these would so that's basically
what wildcards our list of files that
wasn't literally going through every
file going yeah so if you think back we
talked about if you watch the video on
zero size files we talked about how
computer has a directory of all the
files in it so let's just create a
simple directory and let
say we have let's just say we have
lecture zero one lecture zero two we
have lab to see a one you can tell what
I've been doing this week lab zero two
and we've got a file called notes in
there and so these are all separate
files and these are in that catalog for
the current directory so let's say I
wanted to match all the lectures well
then I could use a wild card of lecture
for star to match all the lectures so
how or that should be matched against
each catalog
well that's let's first of all let's see
how it would do it if we just specified
an actual file name so what would happen
if we wanted to search for lab01 because
it's a bit further down so we want to
search for the file lab01 what actually
happens well so it's got a fine whether
that's actually your file in the
directory or not and you have you have a
series of API calls and the operators
allow you to search through deities so
what's going to happen we're going to
come to the first file in the directory
so we've got lecture 0 1 and we've got
lab and once we're looking for the file
lab 1 and the computer is going to
compare the two character so it's going
to compare L&L and they match and it's
then going to compare ena they don't
match so we know that it doesn't match
this one we don't do the same for
lecture 2 and begin the same way we get
to the same point we then come to
compare lab01 and lab 0 once we're
looking for fire lab 0 1 will come to
catalog entry table 0 1 so we compare
the first two characters they match we
compare the second two characters they
match we compare third two characters
they match we compare last but one
characters and we compare the last two
characters and they match and so we
found the file it would actually then
keep going and compare we've left 0 2
and they would not match on the last
character and so it wouldn't match and
the same four notes and then we would
finish so what the first thing we do is
we check every file in the catalog each
time we do it and you could probably
build up the systems and in place to
make you faster whether they do that
another is an implementation issue we
won't go into that so how do we handle
the wild-card well let us think about
traditional window style where we just
mean
anything that follows will match with
the star so let's say we're going to
look for lecture again and we'll do the
same thing to researching the catalogue
through at lecture zero one and we're
going to compare this with lecture star
so we compare the first two they match
compare the second two they match
compare the third two they match and so
on until we get to this point they've
all matched if any of these didn't match
then we'd stop because they don't match
just like we did before they're now in
the windows das world star means
anything after here matches so since we
get to this point and there's a star
here we say well okay doesn't matter
what that is we've matched though this
is a big tick we can use this file do
the same with lecture two and of course
the same thing happens with the others
when we get there
it doesn't match and it carries on so it
builds up a list of results or you have
things that you can go through to
iterate through them and so on you get
the first and you get the next and the
next and the next until you come to the
end interesting point is where is this
actually done in the system and that
depends on the musings of using a UNIX
system this is often done by the shell
so actually when the program gets called
it actually gets called with each of the
different files as different arguments
passed into the UNIX executable to say
we're having to do it itself so of
course you can see how this would then
generalize with say the question when we
come to the question what let's say
we're searching for files match lecture
zero and then some numbers are like zero
four well let's say we use the pattern
lecture zero question mark we compare
each of these just as we did before they
all match now when we get to this point
we see that this is a question mark and
we write the code is it so question mark
that matches with anything of course
this wouldn't match with the file
lecture file name lecture zero because
we'd have the question mark here and
this would be the end of string and so
wouldn't there so we just have to write
the string comparison algorithm to know
about question marks and to know about
stars and the other character codes that
we can use to represent other things
first glance it looks plausible when you
actually read into the comments they're
very bizarre let's pick a couple and see
us I so so this guy by blocky thought
now that might be a real person but it
probably is just a completely made-up
username
I was know pretty puzzling the code
gaming so they would have found out
something tread the largest stop
information I filled this guy hassled
200 as replied I find your own
difference profound certainly haha